you
hello everyone and welcome to today
webinar titled : 19 total solutions for
detection and surveillance this webinar
is part of the ongoing coronavirus
virtual webinar series and i'm susie
valdez of lab route and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes and sponsored by BGI Americas
and MGI Americas for more information
about BGI americas go to WP GI comm
backslash u.s. backslash and for more
information about MGI americas go to wwm
GI America's comm so let's get started
before we begin I want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you'd
like during the presentation to do so
simply type them into that ask a
question box and click send will answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits simply
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain those
credits I now present today's speakers
dr. Pam Zheng a laboratory director at
CGI and mr. Debose min Carr a Senior
Product Manager at Complete Genomics
facility of mgi's for a complete
biography on our speakers please visit
the biography tab at the top of the
screen
starting first dr. pan Xing well you may
now present your presentation
hello everyone thank you for attending
the webinar
my name is pan Joanne I'm the lab
director at BJ Americas today I will
talk about PGI solutions and efforts to
address Kovan 19 pandemic this is the
outline of my talk today which I would
like to cover three topics first of all
I will talk about PGI and gave a brief
overview of the company and also the
current status kovin 19 outbreak second
I will focus on BG i6 our scope to
rt-pcr detection kit which we saved us
FDA new approval on March 26 and next
last I will talk a little bit about
Vijay Chavan 19 efforts in the press so
who are we
PGI is a world-leading life science
organization is provide a wide range of
service to both researchers and clinical
professionals with quality genomic data
and genetic testing solutions it was
found in 1999 in order to participate
the human genome project which is
considered one of the greatest
scientific achievement of last century
it is headquartered in Shenzhen
Guangdong China now BGR has over 6,000
employees worldwide and has provided
services to more than 100 countries and
regions
also have uh crackers inviting
infectious disease especially at the
front of diagnosis VG as the first to
provide HIV AIDS diagnosis in China in
1995 in the 2003 SARS pandemic in 2004
avian flu pandemic PG has a first a
sequence of virus genome and produced
diagnostic kit to detect the black
pathogen in Tucson and lava e.coli
outbreak PJ has also first sequenced the
pathogen in 2014 we help the detection
of Ebola virus in Sierra Leone and in
2020 among the first few companies who
developed the : 19 detection kit BGA has
produced massive detection kit to help
us fight the pandemic this work map
shows the current status of : 19
outbreak the color indicates the number
of confirmed cases in that particular
region and country as of March 30th
there are two hundred and three
countries and regions with confirmed :
19 cases and altogether globally there
are 700,000 confirmed : 19 cases and
related dances as 33,000 and all the
numbers are still growing all this
information are coming from the village
on : 19 situation report 17 in order to
fight fight this : 19 all break whe will
put together strategic objectives this
is a very text heavy and busy slide but
I just want to point your attention to
those keywords such as interrupt human
to human transmission identify early
rapid identification diagnosis and
management of cases so it's clear early
detection and diagnosis will play a
critical role in combat
combating the heartbreak
in United States number of confirmed
cases also growing every day
CDC has published guidelines for
patients house care providers and the
libertà professionals the information
here is from cities a website just to
give you a brief overview of : 19
although there are still a lot to be
learned for this : 19 Caron sinking is :
19 spreads from person to person through
respiratory droplets among close
contacts : 19 symptom can range from
mouth symptoms to severe illness and
that's wrong confirmed : 19 cases
although there are also reports of
patients with the any symptoms usually
the symptoms developed in 2 to 14 days
after exposure those including favourite
cough shortness of breath for a common
19 testing cities also published
criteria to guide evaluation of laborda
testing for Cobain 19 cities he also
recommends clinicians should accuser
judgment to determine if a patient has
signs and symptoms compatible with coma
19 a brother a patient should be tested
so it's very clearly outlined by both
cities in FDA that the comment 19
testing is prescribed by the patient's
health care provider cities also put
together priority list for testing
patients with suspected over 90
infection next I will talk about our
stars cough to rt-pcr detection kit this
is emergency use authorization from US
fda and this is the first page of letter
of our authorization as well as our
press release about that holiday ssin
I do want to put this disclosure before
I talk about the kid in details so no
kid name is real-time for us as rt-pcr
kid for detecting SARS 2019 and cope and
in the United States this test is now
being FDA cleared approved
and has been authorized FDA under a a
for use by authorized laboratories and
only for detection of nucleus it from
source code and under yo a declaration
prior to FDA approval our kids rejection
: 19 already received other regulatory
approvals On January 26 China national
medical products administration approved
for detection kid PGI's Akira Simone of
is one of them On February 28 already
has also received say he IV d and resale
certificate in you for europe region
this kid is qualitative detection of
stars cough two nuclei acid by real-time
reverse transcription PCR it honks off
one a/b of stars co2 virus genome you
can detect nucleuses from patient
samples of stroke swab and above the
sample will be extracted using high and
viral RNA minikit and reactions around
ABI to 7500 each kit contains 50
reactions which including everything you
need for rt-pcr this is a structure of
SARS co2 genome and also several
detection targets that can be used in
lance our scope to genome is about
30,000 base pair it contains several
regions including RF 1a b as e MN r f1 a
b is a huge region the largest region in
the south co2 genome is encoding poly
proteins and one of the protein encoded
its RNA dependent RNA polymerase r dr p
our targets is also on our f1 AV region
but not our dr p but it's also
conservative region other regions such
as a switch for spike protein e4m low
protein as well
and for nucleo capsid protein I can also
be used for targets this is a workflow
for the sample preparation all the way
to use data analysis briefly it can be
divided into three steps first step is
sample preparation including RNA
extraction from patient samples and then
setting up the PCR reaction this step
assuming everything using taking
manually you will take about 50 minutes
after interactions set it up in what it
can be loaded to 7500 real-time pcr
system and running the program the
program itself take about an hour and 25
minutes after the results coming out you
can start your analysis and this usually
take 25 minutes for even less once you
got used to the data as indicated
previously we can use two different
sample types to detect the nucleic acid
of stars called two for lower
respiratory tract we can use both sample
and for our pure respiratory tract shows
what can be used the samples then
subject to RNA extraction using campfire
are in a mini kit and after extraction
the rt-pcr reaction can be set up this
is one step set up so basically the
reverse transcription and real-time PCR
is take place in the one tube the
component in the kit provide all the
necessary region for this to happen so
there's four tubes in the kit
there's reaction mix and enzyme acts the
reaction mix contains region for
amplification probes primers for virus
target as well as internal reference the
enzyme mix is tech polymerase reverse
transcriptase and udg everything you
need for the enzyme to have the
PCR action to take a place there's also
positive control providing the kit which
is a mix of solution studio wireless or
virus-like particles which target virus
gene and internal reference now the no
template control base teaches nucleus
free water so it's very simple to set up
the PCR reaction the reaction volume is
certain my clutter including 10 my
clutter of extracted RNA and 20 micro
letter of PCR mixed and PCR mix
basically the reaction mix and enzymic
so you will have everything in the kit
only three component set of RTP
direction and the table and the lower is
indicating the PCR program you should
need to set up for a 7500 after the PCR
finished you can start the data analysis
so before you move on to any particular
patient sample the first thing is to
determine it's the entire ROM pass or
fail so for everything go wrong there
should be at least one non template
control and one positive control so
first look at the non template control
there shouldn't have any amplification
and the positive control also should
have very good amplification now the cut
off value for city city radio for
internal reference which is big channel
35 and for fans analyst 37 so if both
but here a mad then this wrong pass you
can proceed to sample analysis if non
template control show any amplification
that's indicating of cross contamination
you should fill in tyrona repeat it or
if the positive control doesn't have a
good amplification that's probably
indicating some process arrow either the
extraction or rt-pcr then the entire run
also need to be filled and then you run
it repeated running another time so
after the first QC track if the entire
round pass you can move on to the sample
analysis now the lower table show you
for a possible scenario for any game
example the first thing look at the
internal reference if you say a good
amplification that indicating the sample
paths acute has a good quality and if
there is fam channel amplification
that's a positive or SARS cough - or if
there is not there is an active this it
is an activist article - if you do not
have a good internal reference
amplification the sample fail regardless
you have them application or not this
tests invalid and you should repeat that
simple okay
so let's talk about the performance of
the kit first we look at the limit of
detection of the kit we used the control
material to testing out the potential
limit of detection concentration as you
can say we use five concentrations 500
300 150 175 copies premiere of : 19 and
the number of positive detected in the
total number test it's 20 is all
hundred-percent unto you the 71 to 75
copies per mil which turns in 75 percent
now we decide that that's probably where
the LOD are for the kit however this is
control material so it's always
different from clinical samples and we
want to test it within a clinical sample
so the next step we use clinical patient
sample the throat once from swab and
tube of samples and also do this five
different concentration titration and as
you can say first roll swab at 150 the
detections 19 out of 20 so it's about 95
proportion pasta and we define that as
limit of detection for a strong swab is
150 viral copies per male
now for both one and two one sample ad
hundred hundred copies from mil we have
hundred-percent detection however
another one showed 19 out of 20 so
combined together for the Bob who only
say the 100 copies premier in silver
it's a limited detection for the
specificity and across reactivity we
worked tested 54 pathogens which
commonly you know commonly found in
respiratory tract or can cause other
diseases with similar symptom to the
colon 19 and we found no cause
reactivity so this assay is very
specific for the pono virus regarding
reactivity and inclusivity what we did
is we use clinical patient samples which
has been confirmed with pasta and we
diluted those patient samples into first
5,000 copies per mil and we have 100%
detection rate and that we further
dilute it down to hundred mil 100 copies
per meal which is around the limit of
detection were even lower and you can
say for all the bulk sample we have
hundred-percent of detection rate and
only once no swab has 90% of detection
rate which because due to the higher 100
mil copy premier is actually lower than
its limit detection concentration now I
do want to emphasize this all this
dilution is using an active patient
sample to dilute it down to the last
copy so you can imagine everything other
than the virus corner virus will be in
the mixture however we can still
reliably detect 100 copies per mil at
the level
our kit manufacturers I saw once 3:45
complies currently our manufacturing
capacity is that 300 thousand tests per
day we're working on ramping up to six
hundred thousand tests per day and we
believe we can reach that goal very soon
to date we already manufacture more than
5 million : 19 test kit and b GI lab
already performed more than half million
tests in shin jung-hwan other cities
internationally more than 1 million
tests has been ordered from 72 countries
and regions we also have a warehouse
establishing United States who
distribute locally and last I would like
to mention briefly some of the Vijay
Chavan 19 Everts in the press PGA and
partners build kono virus testing lab in
Wuhan you may heard a fire I lab concept
and there's also being reported by the
genome lab we are very excited by the
FDA you approval for our vgi
SARS co2 detection kit and very soon
because the city business leaders bought
50,000 bji : 19 test kit to help the
local medical center to fight the
pandemic also VG i donate thousand
internal tests to state of Maryland
PGI also has global donation efforts for
corona virus detection kit this effort
has been reported by different media
outlets including genome lab United
States also BGA over nineteen detection
care as being donated by Chinese karma
to other countries such as Phillip
Phillip in to help the local garment to
fight the Cova 19 outbreak to date PJ
already directly donate about 140,000
Colonel virus detection kit
and another 200,000 by charity
organization procurement so altogether
about 340,000 PGI core non-violence
action kit has been donated to different
regions and country to fight the covin
19 outbreak I believe this slice
conclude my talk at thank you for your
time and tension
Thank You dr. Zhang for that
presentation and now I'd like to welcome
our second speaker mr. named Cara
welcome and I'd like you to start your
presentation welcome sir
good afternoon my name is Sibylle NIM
card and I'm the Senior Product Manager
at MGI based in San Jose California
today I would like to introduce you to
be GI and MGRS code 19 total solutions
for detection and surveillance I will be
primarily focusing on sequencing based
surveillance solutions from MGI today I
would like to basically take you through
BGI and NGI's involvement in Kovach 19
detection from day one so I have laid
out the talk in where I will first
quickly go through the covered 19 global
status introduce you to BG i as a group
and our role in testing worldwide then
as I mentioned before I will introduce
sequencing surveillance workflows for
covert 19 then I'll talk about practical
considerations for detection and
surveillance of covered 19 and then get
into more details about what is exactly
required to perform covert 19 detection
and surveillance really well to get the
best results and that involves in swap
reservation transport and storage it
involves an extraction kids and of
course the automation to support the
current needs and then I will summarize
as of March 29th we have roughly six
hundred thirty four thousand eight
hundred confirmed cases worldwide and
approximately twenty twenty-nine
thousand nine hundred
debts as we are all aware the pathogen
now is officially called covered 19
infected people are the primary source
or the only source of infection spread
and it is spread through respiratory
droplets and personal contact as the
epidemic spreads there is possibility of
of mutations in the wires and those need
to be tracked BGI as a group is
primarily split into three different
organization types one is the nonprofit
basically focusing on deciphering
science second is a group of companies
or divisions that are focusing on
manufacturing and providing solutions
around sequencing and third is pure
research groups in the first category we
have BGI college which is basically for
educating young workforce on genomics
second is Chinese national gene bank
which is owned by Chinese government but
operated by MGR and then giga science
journal which is a peer-reviewed journal
managed by and published by PGI in the
second group of companies which are
involved in industrial activity and
providing solutions MGI
which is manufacturing all sequencing
instruments and reagents and kits then
we have fgi which is forensic group
providing forensic services and then in
the Pierrot research in life sciences we
have vgi health and an agriculture
business
vitia has been involved in kovat 19
detection and surveillance from day one
we sequenced first covered 19 genome in
collaboration with a lab in Wuhan built
and operate are still operating a lab in
Wuhan Vijay offers both real-time PCR
tests and ingest sequencing and both
were deployed in in China and so far we
have performed about over 1 million
tests in over 60 countries and the
numbers are rapidly growing very early
covered 19 genome sequencing basically
the workflow that was used earlier on
was collection of swabs extract samples
and then do library preparation as we do
normally for for sequencing perform
sequencing and then buy and traumatic
son Alice's mg is proprietary DnB seek
technology that is implemented on all
the lbc platform was used for sequencing
for by informatics platform vgr and
angeas pipeline was used and in brief
basically the raw data was processed and
first by doing quality control of the
data filter data blasts the the
sequences obtained against NCBI
databases and identify consensus or
similarity between the sequences extract
reads identify context scaffolds and
build the whole genome sequence the
first genome sequence was done around
the symbol 22nd the NBC G 400 was used
seven patient samples with severe
pneumonia six World vendors and shippers
in wuhan seafood market PCR was first
performed using pan theory primers that
showed five positives MPs or massively
paddled sequencing de no assembly showed
about 87% sequence similarity with SATs
Co de no assembly and targeted PCR
basically showed twenty nine thousand
eight hundred ninety one base pair for
coronavirus genome with about seventy
nine point five percent sequence
homology with SAS Co v7 non-structural
proteins common to SARS coronavirus
basically suggested it is Assad's
associated virus the sequence blasted
against ncbi database sure that genes
that produce viral surface glycoproteins
as particularly different between covert
19 and others Czar's family related
viruses we did some more suspected
samples and and this time we use d NB
c-- t7 platform a much higher throughput
platform because the need was increasing
and this was primarily to explore
origins of the virus this was turn
around January 5th 9 both samples were
sequenced over 99.9% genome sequences
were same for 8 samples only four snps
were found
between the two samples wh1 902 and
whu-oh - this basically indicated that
the widest may come from the same source
in a relatively short period of time
Shanghai Public Health clinical center
in a food a university then submitted
sequences to NCBI around January 13 and
and identified Earth's data primarily of
interest to identify the kovat 19 genome
and this data was used now routinely to
do sequencing based genome analysis
further we also needed to put more
instruments to meet the demand so we had
DN BCG 50 instrument also used around
January 21st and and the de novo
assembly using DN BCG 50 and in this
case sequencing was done using single
and 100 about 300 million reached
generated and about 2.5 million reads
from Kovac 19 the de novo assembly using
I DBA basically generated the same data
with the whole genome sequence of about
twenty nine point nine kilobytes
basically indicating all the three
platforms that we reused for kovat 19
sequencing basically generated similar
data and and worked quite efficiently
under these stressful conditions now
going forward there are different
sequencing surveillance workflows
that have emerged and and we wanted to
compare these different approaches men
Feng Shao at at BG I'll lead the
research on this comparative study the
goal was to really validate bias
sensitivity inter-individual raelians
and intra-individual accuracy eight
patient samples throat nasal anal swabs
and spoodle were used in this work also
some cultures were used and culture
delusions were employed to identify the
performance of these different
approaches three different approaches
that we use were amplicon sequencing
meta script omics and hybridization
capture for applicants sequencing
patient samples were process using a
duplex panel and PCR primers used were
basically about 300 to 400 base pair for
cultured samples about 100 to 200 base
pairs sequencing was done using DN BCG
400 using single and 400 sequencing for
a meta script Thomas D NBC t7 was used
and paid Hunt paired and 100 sequencing
was performed for same thing for
hybridization capture the NBC G 400 and
paid and 100 sequencing for a
hybridization captured bouquet panel
probes and blockers were used this is
really the high level workflow for these
three approaches employ for meta script
Tomek and and hybridization the workflow
is very similar in brief host DNA free
ranae's were fragmented double-stranded
see DNA synthesized library prep which
included an repair adapter ligation and
amplification were performed samples
were dual indexed and then mgi's a
proprietary patented technology of
circularization rollers rolling circle
replication and DnB making was used to
prepare samples for sequencing using
parent and 100 sequencing same approach
very similar for capture hybridization
or sorry hybridization captured was used
using the bouquet panel all the steps up
to library prep were similar but after
that the DNA RNA will capture using the
panel and then circularization rolling
circle replication and DnB making
followed by pear and 100 sequencing
amplicon base enrichment workflow using
a duplex panel was following total RNA
was reverse transcribed genome
amplification was done using full and
genome amplicon panel two steps of PCR
product generation and amplification
single-stranded DNA was obtained and
then the standard library prep process
was done and single n400 sequencing
performed this work is all published in
ming in fangs shelves paper at bio
archive the data processing format a
script omics and hybridization capture
was very similar
[Music]
first pass identification of candidate
viral wreaths was done by processing all
reads by aligning with corona radiata
genomes basically a combination database
of tree genomes SARS MERS and covered 19
further qualification was done while
removing low quality reads duplicates
and adapter contamination then the data
was cleaned up further by removing low
complexity reads this generated curve in
nineteen like reads the data was then
further subsampled to only 100x coverage
or more and then the Dean of assembly
was done using spades for amplicon based
sequencing low quality reads were
removed and adapter sequences were
removed and this was done on the single
and 400 reads are using fast P further
qualification was done basically in this
step primer sequences and 21 base
upstream and downstream of the primers
were trimmed the clean reads obtained
were used for downstream analysis
amplicons
sequencing generated an uneven read
coverage pylon then was used to generate
virus consensus sequence and positions
with depth 100 X or Lua or 5 X lower
than the negative control marked as
ambiguous or ends the conclusion and the
guidance from main fence word is really
captured in this slide based on the
world published if the goal of the study
is to to study genetic material
in addition to the target viruses my
desk Atomics is probably the better
approach if the goal is to study virus
ratification due to recombinational
events again meta script omics is
probably a better approach and if the
viral load in RNA samples is higher than
1e 10 to the power 5 copies per ml or CT
value lower than 24 and 1/2 then meta
script Terminix is a better approach if
the study goal is is to do intra
individual variations particularly when
the concentrations are lower than 1 e 10
to the power 5 per ml or CT values more
than 24 and a half then hybridization
capture probably works best and then
lastly if the goal is to identify snv's
particularly when the concentrations are
low lower than 1e 10 to the power 2 per
ml or CT values as high as 35 amplicon
based approach is likely to give the
best results MGI works with several
partners who have expertise in different
approaches we work with Paragon genomics
also for amplicon panel and twist for
Hubbell ization capture and as you can
see from their application nodes
published their performance is is in
line with what we have seen in our
comparative study clearly the panels
used in that competitively comparative
study are different here and the
performance
employing these two different approaches
using different panels may be different
another exciting amplicon based approach
was recently developed by dr. Robert
Salas at Pennsylvania State University
this approach combines rt-pcr and
massively parallel sequencing the big
difference here is an extremely high
level of multiplexing about 19,000 200
samples can be multiplexed and sequence
in one run so the workflow is something
like this swaps collected RNA is
extracted all these RNA samples are bar
coded then reverse transcribed the bar
codes see DNA samples are then pulled
PCR amplified then libraries prepared
sequencing is done and then by
informatics analysis the key to this
approach is computationally designed
roughly 57600 RT primers with highly
unique bar code sequences that link
samples to cDNA products across three
amplicons that are recommended by CDC n1
n2 Sark Steel v2 and rnase p human
control we are working with dr. Salas t2
to evaluate the approach on DN b seek
platforms and as the data becomes
available we will be presenting that in
the near future now coming to the
practical considerations of of detection
and sin surveillance as we know the
swabs need to be collected at
hospitals and collection sites they need
to be transported and then in the
central lab the extraction real-time PCR
prep and real-time PCR happens and the
results are generated if you are a
sequencing lab then the same thing the
swabs need to be transported to the
central lab which does extractions
library protein sequencing and
bioinformatics analysis maintaining swab
sample integrity is key and that is
because it directly impacts the
performance of the rt-pcr and sequencing
and with results in either top quality
diagnosis or poor quality the primary
challenge for stalling preserving is is
the fact that the samples contain DNA
snrnas that can degrade the RNA of
interest or swamp RNA of interest so
maintaining the the levels of RNA that
were in the original samples are
critical the transport and storage
conditions can exacerbate the regulation
so in order to to address this we
offered the swap reservation transport
and storage tube that basically has
about 2 ml of formulation that
stabilizes the collected swab extraction
is the next key step and mji offers are
any extraction kits that are basically
magnetic bead based DNA and RNA
extraction from cell free samples
these are tested thoroughly with NASA
pharyngeal and throat swabs bowel saliva
serum
and culture medium samples the
extraction is compatible with rt-pcr and
sequencing and it is also compatible
with high throughput automation solution
that we offer here is one dataset that
compares extraction efficiency of MGI
and a competitor and as you can see here
the CT values for ng RI are lower than
the competitor values demonstrating that
it has a better extraction efficiency
for automation MJ offers two different
platforms and JSP 100 and in j SB 916
they primarily differ in their trooper
and JSP 100 does about 100 samples a day
and JSP 960 can do about 500 samples a
day they have all the features required
to do extractions and library prep
onboard and these are extensively field
tested because of the fact that these
were deployed in Wuhan right at the
early stage of covert 19 outbreak just
an example of the mdc-t 7 workflow to
give you an idea about the time it takes
to to do the sequencing is basically
about 20 hours four hundred eight
samples or 328 samples from samples to
report at each step enjoy offers a
particular product as we talked about
extraction for library prep the offer
india is alive RNA library prep sets and
for automation automation systems
sequencer and then at the end for
bioinformatics a pathogen infections
identification server and software as I
only talked about these are the three or
four systems that we offer to do Co with
19 surveillance and they primarily
differ based on the throughput and a
number of reads and turnaround time all
of these systems have been extensively
used for covert nineteen in the end MGR
basically offers all the the products
and solutions required to perform occur
with nineteen surveillance in the best
possible manner to deliver top quality
results
so to summarize I hope I have convinced
you that BG I and M G I have gained very
early valuable insights into Kovac
nineteen genome with our experience
right from the beginning and the
products and the solutions that we have
deployed we are in a very good position
to to support initiatives in Co V 19
detection and surveillance we and this
is through other products for RNA
extractions automation swap reservation
and the three different sequencing
approaches that we support and D NBC
platforms our experience and the
products that we offer
I think BJ is in the best position to to
supply robust total solution for Kovac
19 detection and surveillance thank you
and thank you pan and to bow for that
informative presentation and we will now
start the Q&A portion of this webinar
and if you have any questions audience
members you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll get started so we have quite a
few questions already coming in and so
but I'll actually start with you let's
see our first audience member would like
to know are the swab tube extraction kit
and automation available now
yes all the three products that you just
mentioned they are available and that's
whether the automation goes there are
two systems MGR SD 100 and nsj the 960
which basically differ in their
throughput
wonderful thank you and I'll switch back
and forth
Pam here's a question for you is your
test use tax man's technology with
primers and probe or other technologies
yes our kid is actually using testament'
technology
thank you and suppose do you do
sequencing for every sample
so if the question is about what we did
in in Wuhan most of the work of the
sequencing work was initially doing a
sequencing of the genome and then trying
to monitor how how the growth is and
whether there are any mutations so the
short answer is no primary testing was
done using real-time PCR
thank you for that and kind of
continuing with tests about our the 1m
tests performed by BG I use rt-pcr or
sequencing
yeah most of those tests would done
using rt-pcr thank you and again thank
you for these great questions coming in
from our audience we have over 40
questions coming in in any questions
that are not answered today we will be
answering them via email by our
presenters pen what is is in your
positive control
so the positive control provided in the
kit is actually considered what we call
pseudo virus or virus-like particle so
it's target virus RNA in a protein code
and also target a internal reference in
a protocol so actually you can take it
through extraction and through all the
way rt-pcr so it serves extraction
control as the RTP self control and in
10 what is the volume of the reaction
the reaction volume is starting Michael
odor for each sample and you so
basically only why reaction has to be
set up for each patient sample
okay thank you very much and on
regarding samples is your ass a monitor
sample decorative degradation
yes so we have internal reference
reaches targeting humid acting one of
the housekeeping gene so it is in the
same reaction tube to do black so you
will be able to tell if you can detect
the humid acting to tell us the sample
or suing go quality and then the next
step you can look at the Sam Sam which
is the virus channel as a posture
enacted so yes it is actually
implemented in the test reagent
thank you and I'll switch back to
suppose what is the composition of the
two ml formulation used to preserve the
swab sample
a very good question I don't have all
the details of the formulation but at a
higher level I would say that it it does
have chemicals to prevent dnas and RNA
degradation
so basically inhibitors and then there
are some other components that that
maintain the sample integrity as much as
possible at two to eight degrees Celsius
thank you an argument if you do labor
I'm sorry
that was going to say that I can
certainly provide the details offline
wonderful and are the three sequencing
approaches meta transcriptomics h YB
capture and amplicons cons to both
I'm not very clear about the question
but but we mg I on the NBC platform we
do support these three approaches and
depending on on the objective of the lab
a certain approach may be more more
appropriate than the other and I get
another difference between these three
approaches is the throughput that one
can achieve by using these three
approaches so amplicon sequencing
probably has the highest throughput
followed by the hybridization capture
and and then a transcriptomics and when
I say throughput I mean the whole that
includes sample prep library prep
sequencing and data processing
give her that and can what is that what
is about cross-reactivity
with other coronaviruses like stars and
murders not a good question
so Ashley at the beginning when we do
mouthing over a state we actually did
both in silico and West left testing so
so we lab tested the sarsen Mars and
there's no class activity we saw a thing
thank you and did you use clinical
samples or RNA controls for your
validation study Pam
so Ashley's grown-up example for all of
our clinical evaluation so we don't use
our own and controllers our about the
evaluation tool so
you for that and we have a couple
minutes for a few more questions and I
just want to remind audience members
thank you so much for all of your
questions any questions not answered
will be answered via email and I'll give
you one more and then to vote pan do you
have what what are the challenges that
you encounter during developing the test
so we actually so as the door actually
alluded to that we actually have
sequencing capacity in over RDL clinical
lab so at the beginning I will say the
first challenging is to get to know the
sequence of the virus and make sure you
select the right target and test it out
to make sure there's no cross activity
and it's also maintaining the
sensitivity so that is the first
challenge but I think we have this
capability so we we get a doubt at least
verifies the second one I would say is
more challenging for the current
developer in the US and other countries
that a lot of clinical validation which
is very important that awaits the passes
clinical performance is that you prefer
to use clinical samples the real
clinical samples to detect if you can
tell there is a clonal virus infection
or not I know it's a little bit
difficult opportunity at this point in
here we at that time we have we have a
collaborator of clinical laboratories so
we have already access to the sample and
then getting all the clinical evaluation
done so that's I think the major two
challenges that any developer should
probably going to face at this point
that and to vote here's a final question
for you what are and actually it's a
two-part question what are all the
practical advantages of having sequence
data as opposed to rt-pcr data and the
second part is I know you can use the
sequence data to trace the geographic
spread of the virus but what else can
learn we learn from the sequence data
sure great question as I alluded to in
my talk the sequencing is really ideally
suited for surveillance meaning we are
is something we are interested in
monitoring the mutation we are
interested in as as was pointed out in
the question geography spread of the
lightest practically it can also be used
for detection but practically the
sequencing is I suited for surveillance
where you have large number of samples
that can that need to be analyzed of
sequence
but there is no real time pressure
because the the sequencing sequencing
takes significantly longer than real
time PCR so let's say it takes about 20
hours to from sample to report but as I
showed there are approaches that that do
that show the potential to do something
like 20,000 samples in one sequencing
run
so the practical advantage is definitely
in the area of surveillance where you
are collecting samples on a routine
basis to monitor what's going on in the
population and and do it very
cost-effectively
thank you pan and thank you so bowed do
you have any final comments for our
audience before we close today
maybe pan I'll let you go first
unsure so I use this more question
coming up so probably just not enough
time to allow internal questions but
thank you for all you listen to this and
really appreciate the lab group to
organize this event it's very helpful
so we'll try we'll try to answer all the
questions so the email after the event
so please feel free to reach out to us
if any questions or need any further
information about the artificial care
also that we talk it is FDA you approved
so if you visit FDA website there will
be information on our web kit as well so
this is my moment comments thank you
wonderful thank you so much pan into
boat
yeah thank you as far as sequencing goes
MGI as a company is looking for a
research partner / collaborators to
deploy these exciting sequencing
approaches that include extreme high
throughput sequencing using amplicon
based approaches as well as
hybridization capture and of course the
transcriptomics if the interest is for
monitoring mutations in viruses and
geography collisions so if there is any
interest in the research labs please
reach out to us thank you thank you and
thank you pan and thank you both for
your time today and for a very important
research now before we go I'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions and
I'd also like to thank our sponsors BGI
Americas and MGI America for sponsoring
today's webinar questions we did not
have time for today and those submitted
during the on demand periods will be
addressed by our speakers via the
contact information you provided at the
time of the registration and this
webcast can be viewed on-demand through
the end of this year 2020 labrys will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay and we encourage you to share
this email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time bye bye and please be safe and
healthy out there thank you
thank you
you